♪ [upbeat music plays]
Chris Haseman: So the app we're presenting
today is our media player, DoubleTwist.
And so, initially we were
just a desktop application.
And our desktop application would sync
any file in any format to any device.
As we progressed,
we realized that Android was a huge
opportunity to bring that vision
and that need that we think, we thought
we could fill to a much larger audience.
Jason LeBrun: A lot of our product
is based around getting your media
from your computer onto your phone.
And since then,
we've been expanding.
And we just really wanna provide
a premium media experience.
Chris Haseman: So the feature that
we added for the conference--
this conference in particular--
is a tap-to-share application.
Using the Near Field Communication
radio in both of the two devices.
You tap together while a media,
a piece of media is playing
and the NFC negotiates a pairing
between the two phones
and the media is shared
across the two devices.
It works on Wi-Fi,
if the Wi-Fi is available and
it also will use Bluetooth
if there's no network available.
And it lets you share audio
or video with anybody
who has an NFC capable phone.
Jason LeBrun: One of the things I really
like about working with Android
is it's a very flexible platform,
but there's also a huge ecosystem
and it's a very diverse ecosystem,
because there are constantly
these new devices coming out.
There's all these innovative features
that are always popping up.
Chris Haseman: The more people that we
can bring on board with our application,
the more we grow our ecosystem
and the better we can make
our application.
Jason LeBrun: So, if someone told me
they were thinking about developing
on the Android platform,
my first question would be,
"You're just now thinking of that?"
Because, I mean, at this point,
it's an obvious choice.
00:01:34.583,00:00:00.000